hello and welcome to this video playing
to walk hmm I think doesn't he play this
m39 it places a three line half-dozen
yeah one of those lies that I have
really don't like I always think that
something is wrong with good whites
position but it's not that bad I mean
really not yeah yeah I once made the
mistake of taking him which you really
shouldn't do so what's going on here
yeah I need to fight against that
against the b5 Knight Bishop c4 looks
very normal
43 so what he wants to do is not to
seven take take Queen before is at the
point and it doesn't work I can take on
d5 well let's do it I mean it I don't
think you will take on before that's too
simple too simple tactic but in general
I wanted to get rid of the night anyway
so it's okay what actually yeah this
this is the most sensible move yeah so I
can try six
or just bishop a six
and let's do it probably could have
played that a bit quicker this night is
somewhat far away from the c-4 square
okay maybe this is the wager for him to
do it yeah one thing that I'm unsure
office how to how to handle this here
it's not easy
yes got c4
located and take 90 75 or to b6 could
maybe I'm doing something weird I know
it looks weird but it's interesting
takes Queen takes it doesn't do it okay
yeah here I was thinking I should be
okay with Knight h5 and then f5 g3 Wow
okay first I'm going to do this the book
shouldn't be unprotected
preparing to prepare to bring it to f7
so yeah he wants to take him and say at
some point just one day above my bishop
here would be nice to get it activated
okay prepare f7 and maybe Bishop f6 to
g5 he has a bishop c1 dole an
interesting point is I can maybe play C
4 and some I should have known I should
have come to the C file mailing c4 would
have been an interesting point
interesting IDM yeah okay let's not
think about that too much
so why gets go back here now I'm
probably threatening to take only for
now somewhat somewhat threatening pin
then queen g4 play against the e4 pawn
so here it's playing against that again
you can take and play a fall at
something but then d5 is extremely weak
so probably not what he wants to do
interesting with okay now I don't want
you to take this okay
wait what he forgot that he has that
option
it's that spats really
either form takes takes I'm taking the
night and I'm threat the f32 kind of
coincidental that I think it works f3
and Bishop takes me to some we'll check
here I'll or 8b - probably not
93 no no 93 ok so and this one don't
have much time and maybe you can go in 5
maybe
don't know okay it looks very dangerous
[Music]
the shifty for coming kanikama spree
move that
thirty Seconds Quincy to was probably
going to happen genau
checks change tool and then actually
have to be quicker I know that does all
that much but I needed to play quit move
it's still difficult for him to play
this I control the deep horn I can I can
go from there okay yeah yeah what's
lucky here drew p7k play say that that
single move was lucky has a long game
not so much and I came way it's got to
be salmon such as what it is then it's a
draw
it was completely winning a full of
course who gave to em yeah okay bye
squandered away a bit too much time made
it made it tricky yeah yeah okay so yeah
I think I Scott 85 here okay so I need
to be more precise here start with with
the night move okay I want to look at
the middle game Mosca you cannot take
here because of 95 cm that is this looks
very very normal and here there are
certainly a couple of options this is
interesting I think because it makes
this bishop also look quite bad and the
Queen side situation is not so bad I
mean he's not easily getting the e pawn
running then this is certainly okay I
think
his pieces are not so well placed for
the structure so d5 is probably coming
this was looking quite okay everything I
wasted time yeah this I didn't really
take into account and he probably has to
go to see one I don't know this like
Queen takes is an option oh it's better
than yeah that's better right why do I
have to plain that as cannot just go
here okay that seems to be a better for
white to do that at least adds a strong
piece but that's also we cash pawn but
this is so sorry this is good
look t1 and regrouping here and I was at
this shot 90 mblaq look like it's a
better idea to play this five on the
check yeah okay when the digits yes
certainly can couple of from mistakes in
due to time Queen f7 I was just my main
issue one I wanted to play quick moves
and somehow control the issue but this
isn't the best it's quite clear okay we
graph to a simple okay seventeen seconds
you have to have to be quick so long
yeah him he had rookie seven okay okay
so this is equal according to the engine
up I don't know it probably doesn't end
this it might end in some kind of
Perpetual okay guys thanks for watching